okay Hank I'm about to play the song for
Willie let's see how it goes my brother
got this new dog and you really can
ignore Beauty get twenty years the
seventies never before
first yields confused and then a little
wary then bouncing step to the side life
it's nice to bury this silly Willy
watches do this song
[Music]
yes he gets scared of it and he wants to
run away oh now he can relax looking at
me just yawned he was like oh it's not
over Willie hey Willie there's gotta be
more he just almost did the Exorcist
thing for God's sakes I thought his head
was gonna spin around his neck I mean
Hank you just made Willie and me and the
yetis so happy Thanks
somebody didn't ftda